usually when we play what's more likely
it is two binary choices with no middle
ground no flexibility a twist on what's
more likely today you'll see as it
unfolds first who is the team playing on
wild card weekend and there are eight of
them in all that is most likely chris to
win the super bowl well i mean this is
an easy question well it's not an easy
question it's down to two teams right
off the bat i mean we know that's either
the saints of the patriots and right now
for this year i'm picking the saints you
know i think the saints are
um arguably
really the last few weeks i think
playing probably the second best
football in the nfl ever since they lost
to the 49ers i would almost go the
ravens then the saints and then the
49ers i think it's very close i'm just
talking about the play we've seen the
last few weeks but yeah i think the
saints are you know one of the best
teams in football i'm gonna go with them
there
yeah i'm going with the patriots because
as we discussed yesterday while we were
on the air for five years so scared
you're such a patriots are the
terminator hey anybody who was ever
taken down by the terminator when they
assumed the terminator was dead should
have been scared if they had been scared
they would have made sure the terminator
was dead the terminator ain't dead the
patriots of the team playing this
weekend most likely wow super bowl wow
that's the other team you were talking
about right i know you're right i know
yeah okay
who is the team with the first round bye
that is most likely to be one and done
in the postseason all right well you
could probably guess where i uh go with
this one but to me that's the green bay
packers
you know the green bay packers i give
them a lot of credit of course for some
of the ways they're winning football
games they're doing that yes uh there's
a lot of good a lot to like
i don't look at them though
as the same quality football team as the
ravens the 49ers uh the saints the
kansas city chiefs i really don't you
know again there's just issues along the
team i don't think there's enough
explosive weapons on the offensive side
of the ball uh and on the defensive side
of the ball yes things look good you
know last week was a little concerning
again but uh no
not horribly i shouldn't say that i
guess i just don't i don't buy into the
defense all the way quite yet either so
the packers are easily my choice in this
conversation
and the other thing to remember once
upon a time it was impossible to go to
lambeau field and win in the postseason
that bubble was burst remember how it
was burst and when it was burst chris
okay let me think about this was that
bubble bursts was that michael vick and
the falcons was he the first one to do
it right
january 4 2003 the year you would later
be drafted by the buccaneers the atlanta
falcons went in and won
27 to
17 or 27 to seven yeah was the final
score 27-7 and remember the giants game
the year that the packers were 15-1 and
aaron rodgers was the mvp one of the
all-time great seasons i think that was
one of your selections yeah when we
looked at the best individual seasons of
the decade aaron rodgers 2011. the
giants went in there and beat them they
lost to the 49ers at home in the
postseason and colin kaepernick 2013.
last game of brett favre's career with
the green bay packers they lost to the
giants at home then too so yeah they've
had a few
uh certainly have lost that luster that
dominance as far as playoff football is
concerned they're on a two-game home
playoff winning streak the cowboys in
the dez cotted game and the giants in
2016 the infamous boat trip game right i
agree with you though the packers of the
team most likely to be one and done
primarily because the other teams that
have a buy the 49ers the chiefs and the
ravens i i i believe in them and and
look the the next team on the list that
i would be concerned about is the chiefs
just because of their their long history
of losing playoff games at home i would
be very concerned about the chiefs yes
depending upon who they play you know if
it's the if it's the uh as the two seed
they're going to be fake darth vader
comes to town or like you said the
terminator excuse me the terminator i'll
be back right yeah that would be scary
because they have the secondary to kind
of match up with kansas city in certain
ways we know belichick's a genius and
he'll find a new creative wrinkle uh and
you know yeah kansas city's defense is
good but i don't think we're sitting
here calling dominant yeah i hear you
there you know i think that would be
another one that would scare me as well
next one who is the person most likely
to rewrite the narrative during the post
season well this is a tough one this is
a tough one it really is because it's a
little broad and you don't really know
where to go there's not a lot of like
negative narratives about guys i mean
the first two people all right the first
guy i thought about was kirk cousins and
i said i don't think he's rewriting
anything after this weekend not going to
new orleans not dealing with that saints
team i don't think they got a chance so
that's not happening
i do look at carson wentz you know i
think he's in the process of like we're
ripping up the paper and rewriting the
new narrative right now a little bit i
think everybody's realizing what a
special player he is and i think there's
a good chance and i don't know this but
my i have a you know i i think i think
that's a coin flip game i think the
eagles can beat the seattle seahawks in
philadelphia in january on the grass
slow the seahawks down they're more game
plan specific than the seattle seahawks
mike jim schwartz will do some different
things i think they'll learn from the
first time they played where they lost
to the seattle seahawks i think carson
wentz is probably the guy i look at that
can really rewrite his narrative and and
change the perception about him across
the league
well but i also think his narrative is
already being rewritten it is that's the
playoffs right right here here's one
that i'm going to go with and it pains
me to say it and it's a little bit
tongue-in-cheek but it's also of of the
choices out there somebody who can
rewrite their narrative in a positive
way when you consider his playoff
history it's kyle shanahan right sure
because if he has a 28-3 lead in any of
these playoff games he is not going to
blow it 28 to 3 is going to become 56 to
10
and and it's all the more reason for him
to stop on the throat of whoever they
play i feel sorry for anybody that falls
behind the 49ers because he is going to
have the killer instinct full bore
because of what happened in super bowl
51 and i guarantee you they are not
going to let up they are not going to
make bad decisions they are not going to
misplay the clock there is not going to
be any way anyone can blame anything on
kyle shanahan they are not going to blow
a lead if they have a lead and they also
have the team to hold a lead yeah unlike
the the falcons did four years ago yeah
well mike i'm actually really glad you
said that because it's one of the
dumbest narratives out there you know
again you know my stance on that i mean
it's not the offensive coordinator's job
to manage the football game an offensive
coordinator goes out and does what he
does always until the head coach says
hey i'd like to run it here hey we got
to get some time off the clock here i
mean i've never seen anything like it
where the offensive coordinator
got more blame about the managing of a
game situation than the head coach who
was making four times the amount of
money that just it makes no sense we
would never blame josh mcdaniels if that
happened vice versa we would go what the
hell was bill belichick thinking but for
some reason people on the falcons and
everybody just ran with shanahan and
nobody stuck up for him in atlanta that
still bothers me to this day you know
that and i just think it's a totally
stupid false narrative there all the way
well that's true and that's i'm glad you
clarified it because it's not a merited
and warranted narrative but it's out
there and it's all the more reason for
him to perform in a way that causes
everyone to say hey hey maybe that was
dan quinn and ultimately the guy in the
you know we see quarterbacks change the
play all the time if they know that it's
not the play to go and we praise them
for it matt ryan didn't do anything to
put the falcons in a better spot in that
game all right who is the person most
likely to confirm the narrative about
him during these playoffs have you
already mentioned the name
i think we've already mentioned that you
want any kirk cousins yeah well you know
the monday night football game of your
team with your quarterback did not make
me stop
did not make me feel good maybe maybe
that was a setup maybe they did it on
permanently
there was no way they were going to be
the sixth seed so let's go out and be
really really bad in that game so
everybody writes this on it it's well i
well like they went from they went from
a team that i felt like could play with
anyone in the postseason now i look at
them and say they're just done
i'm with you
it really changed my opinion too i had
this conversation with my dad on the
phone last week and it's funny because
we were kind of both saying the same
thing like
gosh what the vikings had just it just
made me lose faith in them that game
that night there was no fire no
leadership you know if the game just
doesn't go the right way kirk cousins
doesn't make any plays to help the team
get over the top or whatever it is but
when we talk about like you know
narratives right i mean you know
okay i mean who's else going to confirm
their narrative i mean lamar jackson is
awesome he's going to confirm his
awesomeness i mean you know who's the
who's another guy
that has a negative narrative right now
in the playoffs like a kirk cousins that
you know everybody else is kind of
positive right so how about this yeah
that's that's just planted one in my ear
andy reed and clock management oh oh
that's a pretty good one stats i hear
you you're right that's another one that
you know we should all watch for yes
definitely uh i think that's very fair
too and you know what's actually funny
now i'm thinking about the other
narrative who changed the narrative i'm
also thinking about ryan tannehill as
well into that conversation but sorry
i'm getting off topic but i just tan
hill's already changed the narrative
yeah it's like carson wentz
in the last month but who else has a
really negative narrative around them
out of the 12 teams in the playoffs i
think we might have just hit the two two
guys right there we we we do for taking
way too long with segments oh we got to
change that now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports